[Musik]
parat für expedition in die unbekannte
weise in die schweiz
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es geht damit man diese krank und
brauche und office kunden bestens
ergänzen flughafen alle nur eis probleme
ihrer partner energiepark und natürlich
wäre jetzt ein paar mini kollege von der
redaktion decken wäre aber ich weiß im
moment das wort und bekennende aber
garantiert mit mona mit ihrer
befürchtung richtig oder brüssel die
griechische wald am strand ins public
müssen
[Musik]
die sendung heißt notruf gewartet
diese unsicherheiten statt
das circle baustelle mit flughafen
baustellen stellung durch liegt mit uns
verbringen
du bist das mona vetsch tag auf der
großbaustelle aufnimmt vorbereitet abruf
alles gefasst
das ist mona mit drin
da stehen wo wir jetzt die arbeitslosen
oder vierten punkt in halle 2
da man noch vor allem den hals aber
nachher baustelle kann ich bis jetzt
muss das ist gerade noch gegrüßt die
hoch baustellen für die schweiz kurze
der flughafen ergänzt mit hotel
restaurant und leider und sogar einen
teil vom unispital zürich auftraggeber
von projekten der flughafen zürich und
versicherungskonzern swiss life tag und
nacht wird bald 2500 lose
[Musik]
die staatsoper stopps mit dem philips
portugals und wegschauen
ich will einen kran hängt zum schauen
dass wir drüber objekte mehr
damals relativ ziehen so major aus und
rückt
[Musik]
über 50 cent wird er am 1
jetzt hatte ich werde mir selbst und
garantiert mit satchmo mini grenzen
aufzeigen
der von citywire seite verlebte er ist
gelernter goldschmied und sieht acht
jahren mit frauen kennen jeden spiels er
hat sich zum vorarbeiter ruf geschaffen
auf widerruf stege sich schwierig
auf der baustelle hat forschen
portugiesisch mit dem hub zur spitze
aber die können bieten noch bis
vorarbeit und polier und kalium
bush
[Musik]
die größte gefahr sieht wendig durch
eine höhere lang lang hatte man das
gerne noch eine führung
was nicht das was auf der baustelle ist
sehr wichtig offen oder weil es
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also ich bin sehr schmal aufgestellt
was muss man das so vorstellen was ist
wichtig zu machen oder eine rücknahme
von gut
jetzt mache ich so
[Musik]
der kunde
ja
der besuch beim antonio doberaner muss
warten
der baustelle claudio für pcs unter
stapel zudem uhren claudio selber malen
musik sie beförderten karriereleiter
stück für stück thunfisch
[Musik]
und dann auch so ganz da mache ich mit
ganztagsbetreuung und je nach qualität
zum beispiel doch alles passieren
es kostet also locker und tauschen
konnte ziel und service mein lehrmeister
ist dem aus vor zwei jahren ich wusste
schon vorarbeit
er zeigt mal wieder ein richtiges spaß
macht
ich mache das nicht nur noch jene rostig
sie hilft es wenn man das pflaster
relativ grad machen da ist einfach der
steuer absetzen
ja
einfach probieren hier aber probieren
sie mal ein erster aber ich mache ich
das eigentlich wie immer weniger jungen
i war schavan den bau der oberstufen
beosound 5 encore sie der familie dass
man sich ihre handwerklichen gaddafi als
team ist dass unser job macht
fortschritte aber ich sag euch gut
machen also ich hab sie bezieht davos
gespielt von der auslinie wurde so
billig seite fußball oder morgens dauern
ob er einen job machen können wir
eigentlich machen was man am ende nicht
erledigt im parlament
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der schnellste murat dugan gerade mal
drei sekunden pro stein der accord murat
vorschnell den schatten
außerdem bin ich noch weit weg jetzt
geht's los mit meine erste eigene moore
es so der rookie baustelle dort offenbar
recht schnell auf mich abgefärbt
das problem ist wenn man der steinhof
gehört dass man sie aber ruhe
groß
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich haben sie noch einen tag
auf dem bau zu ganz entspannt ich nehme
meine schön sie ist einigermaßen grad
aber sicher erst nach vier stunden es
war vollbracht
[Musik]
er heißt achtung claudia jetzt lag dass
ich jede toleranz zeigen würde dass wir
akzeptieren den bereich audi sport oder
fällt also mit skurriler getäuscht
vorgesehen so glich das spiel zwischen
dinge vorgestellt teil ist auch für
deutschland bringen vielleicht stoßen
dasselbe tut ich will mir auch alles
hinwerfe abo denn das museum nach zwei
vom bild her
man ist öffentliches gut es wird nicht
vor ich glaube dass ich so gut haben und
diesen sport monate gut also dass gott
mich jetzt nicht beruhige aber zum
schluss ist aber trotzdem die panzer
wieder abbrechen oder und im prinzip der
studie eigentlich gestein zu regnen
sodann die steirer wiederum verwendet
da gilt null toleranz diffus wie stark
werk alles wieder zurückbauen
der lauf hilft mit erkennbar sei
[Musik]
übernachtet den iwf oder gerade um die
ecke zwei säle in einer unterkunft
gestellt ist von der baufirma ich fahre
mit dem sami und dem alias mazedonien
die 8
[Musik]
wie viel wir hin dass durch hinten super
sagte post schon der zehnte roten mohn
twitterst du immer
marco grigoli war nicht normal ist sagt
nicht besser ja aber du wirst nicht
wähler das dänische in der hand auf der
baustelle auf wir haben beschlossen die
vorstoß arabis studieren sowie ein
bankkonto bei einer 140 machen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
so ist bizarr die vorstellungen im
moment
[Musik]
dorf die großbaustelle bin ich die
einzige frau die einzige beläuft
diese liegt mit dem pedro frühere ski
ist ihre heimat portugal hat er in einer
schuhfabrik schaffen diese lücke gilt
als der härteste job für den bau stehen
aber petrus ist wahnsinnig schwer
schwester immer so ja immer so machen
sie weiter machen
[Musik]
und jetzt mit familie erwarb familie da
bliebe eigentums bauer oder meine
freundin nach funktion
aber wer weiß
[Musik]
wir schaffen ja aber dann probiert schon
und den usa
da ist antonio
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
so wie ich das nicht mit ihr haben wir
dann schon mal auf der job geschäft der
lohn im vergleich zum juni ihre heimat
aber punkt 50 franken
[Musik]
und ich denke auch dass das gut gemacht
werden die lauter lachen und der
baustelle chef claudio ist ein
kontrollgang er muss nur geld als der
fahrplan von großprojekten und südafrika
krolo abschläge nach wenn der baustelle
ist ein extrem komplexe geschichte
logistisch user fordert sogar für das
milliarden-projekt der circle ist größte
projekt was in ihrer karriere um das
letzte große unfall die vielfältigkeit
vor allem auch bis zur realisierung nach
einer schönen stadt als einmal gemacht
hat erzählt körperliche dem sind habe
durch dynamik bewirkt und das ja hier
baustelle erlebten das ist so
dollar
der claudio und system erwartet wird
hören
der architekt ich bin wie vor der
baustelle beschrieben
wuchtig und gebäude und durchgang
der haken yamamoto will sich das bild
machen vom aktuelle stand von der
baustelle seiner mit dem
gesamtprojektleiter vom sorgt ein bh gut
vorne sehr wichtig er hält die stütze
das sind sehr schmale stützen unterhält
sie sehen ganz wieder vor dass ihnen der
virtuose musik 400 stütze und hochfeste
betont da ich diesen dunklen wieder zum
endbericht und er zieht sich der regen
ja dass sie dunkel des hörers fernhält
und wir unterstützen hellmold den
heimischen bürgerliches themen mitmischt
und auch immer richtungswahl jetzt ist
es wirklich preis zurückverlegt nun mit
der fassade oder dach sind sie zum
prozess um dirigent und dem radio ri wir
machen schluss dass es stimmt
zwar gibt sich in sachen muss man
verhandle zum ferraris optimum zu
erreichen
64 bit unterkunft
hallo ihr könnt nicht etwa die seele zu
deren waren sie nicht in den himmel
mirja million möchte haben wir vor allem
am morgen nach serien wie sie haben auch
die was ich mache
der scharf greift immer nur von mir
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wieder anschauen geschaffen mit dem
federico und sein vater angelo sie
roßlau die dahlie und sind erst seit
kurzem dort
nicht alle firmen konkurs gegangen
zitat zukunft sie wohne die männer
ziehen amro provisorisch ihres leiters
equipe staffellauf spitzley entwurzelt
es ist nicht schön im ort - zwei andere
aber bezwungen
federico und sinnvoll sind so sein
manager
auch seien nötig liegen vorstellung von
der zukunft familie für mich gründe
jetzt muss ja eigentlich zum antonio ich
lasse mir schließlich versprochen
auf der armen
wir tranken schwarzem oberteil
ganz großes kino wie schön die drei
bühnen wo man sich ja vorstellen
[Applaus]
kurzzeitig lupe wenn du uns sagt da
rahmen für ihre nicht
konzentrationssache ich nehms baustellen
[Musik]
streng nächstes jahr wieder am tag
darauf dass orban stellt prof stolz
darauf was sie tagtäglich leisten
[Musik]
ich bin noch drei deckt sehr dankbar
dass sie den job so gut machen
[Musik]
petrow
der giro und sein sohn der federico
[Musik]
der lauf mit einer engelsgeduld audio
und ali andere bauarbeiter in diesem
land wunder hochdruck an der schweiz hat
zukunft baut
so claudio simone dank auf die größte
hoch baustelle für die schweiz gegangen
aber alle anderen stehen ab morgen am 6
[Musik]